lo que tenemos aquí son tres funciones
distintas la primera es una función
multi variable porque tiene dos
variables de entrada verdad y tiene sólo
una salida verdad las otras dos son
funciones digamos tradicionales de una
variable de entrada y una salida verdad
y lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la composición de estas
funciones es decir vamos a tomar la
función x dt como la primera componente
de la entrada de la función entonces
tendríamos la función f
evaluada en x dt como primera componente
y también vamos a evaluar en la función
7 como segunda componente verdad y
digamos la imagen que puedes hacerte en
la cabeza para entender estas
composiciones que digamos de alguna
forma nuestra variable t vive en la
recta verdad vive en la recta y luego
tendremos una función que digamos nos
manda a la variable t
en el plano verdad tendremos
el plano el plano x de verdad y tenemos
entonces una función que nos manda a la
recta oa la variable de verdad en el
plano y finalmente tendremos otra
función que nos manda el plano en
nuestro espacio de salidas verdad que la
representamos con nuestra función
entonces a final de cuentas lo que
queremos hacer es calcular la derivada
de esta composición y cómo podemos
darnos cuenta en realidad es una
derivada ordinaria verdad porque a final
de cuentas tenemos una sola entrada que
es nuestra variable t&c y tenemos una
sola salida así que es una derivada
ordinaria y en realidad para hacer esto
podríamos utilizar lo que se conoce como
la regla de la cadena multidimensional o
multi variable verdad pero en realidad
en este ejemplo no la vamos a necesitar
y digo no es que nunca se utilice la
regla de la cadena verdad en realidad es
una herramienta teórica muy útil para
comprender la composición de funciones y
comprender cómo son los cambios verdad
es decir cómo son las derivadas de esas
composiciones de funciones entonces lo
primero que podríamos hacer nosotros
aquí es justamente sustituir quién es x
dt y t entonces en esencia tendremos
nuestra función f evaluada en la
primera función que es coseno de t y en
la función seno de verdad como segunda
componente y recordemos que queremos
calcular la derivada de esa función
verdad ahora bien nosotros podríamos
sustituir coseno de t y seno de t en la
función verdad entonces tendríamos x
cuadrada que en este caso sería coseno
de t todo esto elevado al cuadrado y
luego multiplicamos por de verdad que en
este caso sería el seno de t y esto es
lo que queremos derivar con respecto a
nuestra variable t y entonces en este
momento quizás te estarás preguntando
por qué te estoy mostrando cómo tomar
una derivada de una función tradicional
y es que en realidad esta derivada nos
da la idea de cómo es la regla de la
cadena multivariable entonces si
nosotros hacemos esta derivada verdad
podríamos digamos tomar esto como la
derivada de un
entonces la derivada de un producto
sería la primera verdad el primer factor
por la derivada de la segunda verdad del
segundo factor que en este caso sería la
derivada del seno de t que es coseno de
t entonces multiplicamos por el coseno
de t más ahora tendremos que derivar
esta primera verdad y multiplicar por la
segunda entonces la derivada de esta
primera sería dos veces el coseno de
verdad aquí aquí en esencia lo que
estamos haciendo es la regla de la
cadena aquí podríamos pensar que es x
cuadrada verdad y al derivar x cuadrada
sería 2 veces x y luego por la derivada
de x que es la derivada del coseno dt
verdad entonces sería dos veces coseno
de t por la derivada del coseno de
teques - el seno de t y todo esto
multiplicando a todo esto estará
multiplicando
seno de t
seno de t muy bien entonces voy voy
simplemente a copiar esto mismo aquí
abajo pero lo voy a arreglar voy a
cambiar el orden para que podamos ver un
patrón muy interesante entonces aquí
será dos veces el coseno de t ahora voy
a multiplicar por el seno de t y esto va
a multiplicar a menos el seno de t en
esencia lo único que hice fue invertir
el orden de estos factores ahora bien
esta es la derivada de una composición
de funciones y lo que quiero hacer ahora
es simplemente una observación en
términos de las derivadas parciales de
nuestra función
efe muy bien entonces vámonos más más
abajo de hecho voy a seleccionar esto de
aquí para copiarlo y pegarlo más abajo
y vamos a pegar lo más abajo
muy bien solo para que lo tengamos muy
presente y ahora vamos a calcular las
derivadas parciales muy bien calculemos
entonces las derivadas parciales
tendremos la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de x en este caso x será
nuestra variable y sería una constante
derivamos esto respecto de xy nos da 2x
por la constante que en este caso es de
y ahora calculamos la derivada parcial
de la función con respecto a iu y esto
nos da bueno pues si x cuadradas como
una constante derivamos ye y eso es 1 y
simplemente nos da nuestra constante que
es x cuadrada y este patrón que tenemos
con las derivadas parciales aparece en
el resultado que obtuvimos anteriormente
por ejemplo aquí tenemos 2x porque si en
lugar de poner x ponemos coseno de t y
en lugar de ye ponemos seno de t
justamente aparece aquí y es por eso que
quise invertir el orden para que fuera
mucho más claro verdad
ahora bien en la equis cuadrada aparece
justo de este lado verdad sería x
cuadrada y aquí x es coseno de t
entonces se vuelve coseno cuadrado de t
muy bien y por supuesto falta determinar
quiénes son los otros factores y eso lo
podemos hacer derivando la función x con
respecto a t y derivando la función con
respecto a t entonces si derivamos x
tendremos la derivada del coseno que es
menos seno es - seno de t y la derivada
de con respecto a que sería la derivada
del seno de t que sería coseno de t
entonces justamente menos seno de t
aparece aquí y coseno de t aparece acá
verdad entonces al menos en este ejemplo
parece ser que la derivada de nuestra
composición se ve de la siguiente forma
se ve como la derivada parcial de f con
respecto de y verdad
multiplicando
a la derivada de que la derivada de y
con respecto a t verdad que es coseno de
t y tenemos otro sumando que sería esto
de aquí que es la derivada parcial de f
con respecto a x que multiplica a menos
seno de t que en este caso sería la
derivada de x con respecto a de verdad y
por supuesto cuando digo aquí la
derivada parcial de f respecto de y
respecto de x en realidad esto tiene que
ir evaluado en los valores que tenemos
para xy ya que en este caso son
funciones y son coseno de t y que de
verdad son justamente estas funciones de
las que estamos hablando y en realidad
esta fórmula que acabamos de obtener
tiene un nombre y se le conoce como
regla de la cadena multivariable incluso
podríamos ponerlo digamos en general
tenemos que la derivada con respecto
de la composición de f evaluada en la
función x de t y así digamos en general
se puede calcular como la derivada
parcial de nuestra función f con
respecto a x verdad multiplicando a la
derivada de la función x con respecto a
t verdad y luego sumamos la derivada
parcial de f con respecto a y
multiplicando a la derivada de g con
respecto a t por supuesto aquí solamente
hemos invertido el orden de los sumandos
pero no debe causar ningún problema y en
realidad existe una versión más general
de la regla de la cadena pero digamos
esto que hemos obtenido aquí es el caso
más simple verdad que podemos tomar en
donde en realidad empezamos con una
dimensión verdad tenemos una dimensión
luego pasamos a dos dimensiones con una
función verdad y luego regresamos a una
dimensión en el próximo vídeo voy a
de la intuición de por qué esta fórmula
de la regla de la cadena es cierta en
general verdad o al menos para funciones
que sean que podamos derivar verdad y
aquí vimos un ejemplo y mostramos que
resultaba ser cierto pero pero en
realidad hay un bonito razonamiento
detrás de por qué esta fórmula es cierta
también hablaré de una forma digamos
generalizada en donde usaremos una
notación vectorial y se verá mucho más
limpio y quizás también después veamos
un argumento más formal de por qué esto
es cierto nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo